It's like the life of a poison taster isn't right for
me. Maybe I'm the only one who enjoys eating poison. In any case, it's good for a
married couple to soak their internal organs
into soup. I can't help but feel the numbness in my lower part.
[Laughs]  ]
Hey,
this eggplant is Sanmon's favorite food.Even in the high-end food, it's
sometimes served.Usually, blue fish is used.But
today, there's no way that a little foodie who's in charge of jellyfish or Sanmon's food would
mistake the mineral ingredient.The King of Eggs doesn't
like it either.  There's nothing special about it, so I took the wrong abandoned train line.
[Music] Maybe you do
n't like fish, so you can't leave the taste behind. I saw
something disgusting. Every time I saw it, there was a
poisonous person of the opposite sex. I
ate in fear.  Just look at what's so funny about her appearance. Hey, that
poisonous Ji-chan.
[Music]
Or [
Music]
How good is she? [
This is poisonous
[Music] It's
true that the soup of danger is poisonous.
The minister must have taken the poisonous medicine. Why is it so difficult to clean? An
adult collapsed after drinking the soup.
[Music]
It's the medicine.
JA